The first thing we're going to do is look for two numbers that add to equal
negative 28. So we can write this middle coefficient in expanded form and factor
from there. We know that those two numbers also need to multiply to equal the
product of these outer two coefficients. So, 5 times negative 12 in this case,
which is negative 60. So, what adds to equal negative 28 but multiplies to equal
negative 60? Well, 60 is just equal to 30 times 2. So, we have negative 30 times
positive 2, then negative 30 plus 2 equals negative 28. So those must be our two
numbers. That means we can rewrite this expression as 5 x squared plus the
quantity 2 minus 30 times x minus 12. I personally think that's the hardest part
of the problem, is figuring out how to rewrite that middle coefficient. From
here, it's pretty straightforward. Now, we just factor within the first two
terms and then within the second two terms. We recognize a common factor of 5 x
plus 2. And finally, we get to our official answer of 5 x plus 2 times x minus
6.